haben sie sich schon mal überlegt wenn
sie jetzt gerade im urlaub sind und uns
sehen wie sie überhaupt nach hause
kommen und was sie da genau machen
müssen
dazu haben wir ein video von dennis
brandt aus berlin da schauen wir eine
schöne grüße aus dem risikogebiet
mallorca
wenn ich nächste übernächste woche nach
deutschland zurückfliegen
ich kenne nämlich hin und her und hier
vor ort einen test machen und dieser
test ist negativ also ohne befund dann
muss ich doch nicht in quarantäne oder
ja so soll es sein wenn sie im urlaub
ein problem haben dann nehmen sie
einfach ein handy video auf direkt auf
der liege und schicken sie uns das an
kempkens kennt sich mit diesen ganzen
regelungen sehr gut aus wie ist das wenn
ich jetzt aus mallorca zurück komme also
grundsätzlich muss man in quarantäne und
zwar zwei wochen aus allen
risikogebieten
und wenn man einen negativ test aus dem
urlaubsland mitnimmt dann wird man
sozusagen im moment sofort aus der
quarantäne entlassen
welche tests aus welchen ländern
anerkannt sind
dann können wir sehen auf der seite des
robert-koch-instituts da steht nämlich
genau drin spanien mallorca werden die
test anerkannt in deutschland wir haben
allerdings eine änderung ab dem 1
denn dann muss man in den zwangs
quarantäne
trotz eines negativen tests und dann
wird es etwas anders im moment keine
quarantäne
bei vorlage eines negativ tests ja aber
trotzdem vermisst dass möglicherweise
auch den urlaub wenn man weiß man muss
sich nur um einen test kümmern ist halt
die frage ob man den am flughafen noch
machen kann was er kostet wenn man vor
allen dingen auch das ergebnis bekommt
denn mein chef möchte ja vielleicht auch
wissen ob ich negativ bin wie sehen sie
das
das ist tatsächlich so deshalb sollte
man sich frühzeitig darum kümmern die
anerkenntnis frist ist ja 48 stunden
älter darf der test bei einreise in
deutschland nicht sein
dieser negativ test und wird er eben
auch nicht anerkannt das muss ja
nachgeholt werden und deshalb ist es
natürlich gut man kümmert sich
frühzeitig darum wenn man dann sieht
dass man vielleicht noch auf das
ergebnis warten muss und gar nicht im
betrieb erscheinen muss
dann sollte man unbedingt sofort kontakt
aufnehmen zum chef damit dass eben
besprochen werden kann
ansonsten droht abmahnung und im
extremfall sogar eine kündigung